Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dylan
from Massachusetts. Dylan, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hi there. How's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Speaker 3: That's good to hear. So if
I didn't were to, by executive order,
set up abortion clinics on federal land in
states that have banned abortion. Do you
think that there's anything that those states
can do to stop those clinics from functioning?
Speaker 1: You know, I'm sure that there are
things they can try to do with new arguments that
we've not heard used before. But it would be sort
of like a VA hospital in a sense. Right. Where
when in fact, I remember a story from growing up
in Massachusetts where at a VA hospital there was
like a nurse that killed a bunch of patients
by deliberately giving them too much or the
wrong medication. And it was subject to the death
penalty, even though Massachusetts didn't have it
because it happened in a federal facility. And
I believe that along the same lines, if federal
facilities wanted to offer abortion services, even
in states that have banned it, I think it would
be very difficult for the state to supersede
or come in and do anything about it. I mean,
it would have to be tested and there would be a
test, but it sounds like it would be pretty solid.
Speaker 3: Hmm. Yeah, because I've heard
arguments from people who say that that's a
bad idea for Biden to do that by executive order.
Like, for example, if a state were to arrest
like someone like a doctor going on site
before or after they leave the federal land.
Yep. For having committed the crime of
doing an abortion procedure on federal land.
Speaker 1: That would get very dicey. That
would that would get extremely dicey because
it's not like a it's not like an embassy.
Right. A VA hospital or a federal hospital.
It's not like an embassy where literally no
rules apply. But, yeah, I mean, it's a it's
really a complicated legal question.
Speaker 3: Yeah. If you if you could
snap your fingers and compel Joe Biden to set
up these VA abortion clinics on federal land,
would you or would you not compel him to do that?
Speaker 1: I'd have to think about it. I would
really have to think about it. I mean, the ideal
thing would be to codify Roe v Wade. But that's
not up to Biden. That's up to Democrats
in the Senate. They don't have the votes.
I would want to know more about it before
I took a really strong position on it.
Speaker 3: I'm of the same opinion. Do you do you
think if Democrats get the votes after, you know,
by some miracle, this midterm elections,
do you think that the Supreme Court would
allow Roe to be codified into law?
Speaker 1: I from what I've read,
it would be very difficult for
the Supreme Court to stop it.
Speaker 3: Now. All right. Well,
thanks for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Dylan from
Massachusetts, very much appreciate the call.